the first thing I have to ask you is the
title of the special shrimpin ain't easy
now
I'm always announcing a comedians
special title and it usually makes sense
to me
shrimping ain't easy makes no sense to
me what is shrimping well I guess it I
know what it means to me okay
but apparently it's like super gross sex
stuff yeah is that true well shrimping
to me I have this meat seafood revenge
seafood revenge yeah okay once you tell
me what seafood revenge is well okay so
my mom bought me a book when I was in
high school about revenge
and what what kind of mother does that a
crazy Sicilian one and she has a lot of
grudges I don't know what she had the
book and then gave it to me and it comes
from the story where a woman in England
I guess she was cheated on by her
husband they kicked her out of the house
and then she still had the keys so she
went in there and she put shrimp and
prawns inside the curtain rods and then
they couldn't find the smell so they
tried to fumigate it and then they sold
the house lost all their money and she
watched with glee as they took the
curtain rods and put him in the moving
van and drove so that's the story that
was in the book and that's how you know
shrimp and his stuffing shrimp somewhere
when you want to get revenge exactly and
then for some people I guess there's a
family shows you can't really say no no
Alec Baldwin broke it I used I dropped
an f-bomb in the monologue it's all the
whole things but I guess it's a sucking
toes yeah I forgot can we read yet
[Applause]
well you know that on the weekends I'm a
freelance sex therapist yeah I've cured
half of Burbank okay
these are gross to me yeah like my wife
has the thing where she is the big toe
but then the second toe is bigger yeah
must be thrilled with you telling people
hey ow so have you done this to people
have you ever shrinking that's why I
called the special stripping and easy
because I did that thing where you uh
shrimp your daughter's dance studio
under the daughters dance studio why
would you do that they I have an anger
problem and waits a long story you mean
you mean you planted shrimp there I hid
shrimp oh my daughter yeah okay we jump
from definitions there no no we all knew
what we were talking about okay your
that's your problem so there's stuff in
you went because why would you why are
you so mad you went into their dad earth
dance studio and secretly hid shrimp and
I had shrimp everywhere I'm not the
first guy to think of this I'm not it
was a thing and something had ticked you
off about the watch the special it's a
long okay don't worry I don't want to
give it a go but I just I got really
irritated and then I asked my wife I
called her I go where are we ever coming
back here again
and she goes no absolutely not then I go
and I'll take care of this I hung up
shrimp the whole place
you